[Musique]
bonsoir à vous alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france
ce projet de loi climat et résilience il
prévoit la création de zones à faibles
émissions dans toutes les agglomérations
de plus de cent cinquante mille
habitants d'ici 2025 en quoi ces mesures
renforcent les inégalités feu lanvaux
ces zones à faibles émissions risquent
de devenir des zones à fortes exclusion
en réalité parce que le climat a bon dos
et une fois encore ce sont les mêmes qui
vont traquer c'est à dire les français
qui n'auront pas les moyens de s'équiper
de nouveaux d'acheter une voiture moins
polluante de profiter des primes pour
acheter du nouveau matériel
on comprend bien depuis des années
l'objectif des villes notamment paris à
la capitale c'est de rendre la ville
impraticable pour les voitures à la fois
par la circulation par le stationnement
rendues difficiles et par le prix donc
là par exemple cet été le leur de
stationnement à paris va passer à 6
euros de l'heure
donc si vous n'avez pas les moyens par
il vous est interdit on est en train de
remettre en place un octroi moyen-âgeux
qui va empêcher finalement les non
résidents d'accéder au saint des saints
au centre ville et où vivent donc on est
là dans des lois qui sous couvert de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
sont en fait des lois d'aggravation des
inégalités et qui touche encore et
encore les mêmes français ce qui était
par exemple lors du mouvement des gilets
jaunes descendus dans la rue parce que
rappelez vous c'était aussi une taxe aux
climatique
à l'époque l'essence coûtait moins cher
qu'aujourd'hui donc c'est vous dire que
là on remet une pièce dans une machine a
ras-le-bol pour des français qui ont
l'impression d'être toujours oubliés des
politiques climatiques et politiques
publiques alors parlé d gilet jaune
justement est-ce que cela peut attiser
la colère
nouvelle mobilisation enfin renouveau
justement du mouvement d'aidé gilet
jaune à une relance plus tôt alors les j
oui c'est vrai que les mouvements des
gilets jaunes existe toujours il est
évidemment n'a plus la même ampleur
auparavant il a évolué il ya des groupes
maintenant qu'ils travaillent sur la
démocratie participative sur le ring sur
la la la constituante
il ya eu beaucoup de scission beaucoup
de fatigue aussi jérôme rodriguez le
disait il ya quelques jours
qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé dans
l'histoire on a été mutilée on a perdu
des yeux et puis rien nous sommes les
perdants en fait de la faire on se rend
bien compte qu'on n'a pas changé quoi
que ce soit dans les politiques la
preuve aujourd'hui on voit bien que
l'exécutif contre continuer l'agenda des
réformes continue et les lois climatique
inégalitaire l'agenda des réformes c'est
bien sûr la réforme des retraites qui
est sur la table tout cela comme si tout
allait bien comme s'il ne s'était rien
passé
emmanuel macron pense que en se met en
scène dans des dans des pérégrinations
il appelle ça les déambulations dans les
villages français de manière très
propagandistes ça va suffire avec des
faux grand débat c'est ce qu'il avait
fait pour les gilet jaune rappelez vous
bien il est en train d'essayer de faire
la même chose cet été pour relancer sa
candidature en 2022
il l'avait fait aussi lors des élections
européennes tout ça je ne sais pas si ça
va suffire parce que le mécontentement
est réel
hélas ça n'a pas changé au contraire je
crois que la colère n'a fait
qu'augmenter depuis 2018
on parle beaucoup de déconnexion de la
part du pouvoir des connexions encore
est ce que il
cela représente véritablement un danger
pour la cohésion sociale du pays
il ya quelque chose un peu effectivement
de fascinant de voir comment notre
époque moderne ressemble à l'ancien
régime
on a d'un côté une caste qui s'auto
appelle les élites qui va très bien
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron recevait
edouard philippe et sa famille au palais
de l'elysée ils ont dîné déjeuner pardon
sur la pelouse et lui remettait les
insignes de grand officier de la légion
d'honneur tout ça comme si tout allait
bien comme si il n'avait pas reçu une
gifle il ya quelques semaines comme si
il n'y avait pas des signaux d'alert
partout leur farine agen de jean luc
mélenchon de 2,2 du candidat de la reine
monsieur de rugy et c'est un ras-le-bol
réel en fait des citoyens par rapport
aux politiques qui ne les représentent
plus vraiment et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
vie séparée dont les palais dorés de la
république avec les soubresauts les
craintes du père n 1 français sur dix
sous le seuil de la pauvreté combien
aujourd'hui de concitoyens qui ont peur
pour la suite à savoir s'ils vont garder
leur emploi ou non les plans sociaux les
ministres font campagne pour les
élections régionales mais oublie les
usines qui ferment et elles sont
nombreuses
et puis s'est mise en scène perpétuel et
la politique politicienne qui
n'intéresse plus personne
alors d'accord marine le pen a peur qu
eric zemmour la dépasse sur sa droite
mais au final à quel moment
aujourd'hui on va parler de programme on
va parler de faire attention à ce qu'ils
ne sont rien ce type her2 tout comme le
disait et macro ils sont toujours les
oublier et est aujourd'hui clairement le
fait de vouloir continuer malgré un ce
ras-le-bol populaire malgré ce désamour
ça fait le jeu des grands partis qui
vont dire un taux d'abstention record ça
ne change rien finalement
au résultat des élections nous
arriverons à sauver des sièges et à être
élu mais rien est écrit 2022 est encore
loin et il se pourrait qu'un mouvement
populaire arrive pour changer l'agenda
refuser les réformes qui sont toujours
ramené sur la table malgré la
conjoncture économique et changer la
donne
alors qu'aujourd'hui mail macron semble
suivre sa feuille de route c'est à dire
faire peut-être des choses dures qui
l'empêcheront de se présenter alors
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui dans les
jardins de l'elysée c'était une
passation de pouvoirs sans dire entre
emna le maquereau et son ancien premier
ministre
edouard philippe qui va reprendre la
relève si jamais volé le maquereau ne
peut pas se présenter parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui le pouvoir se
prépare à des soubresauts sociaux à la
rentrée une piste à suivre donc merci
beaucoup alexis paul un éditorialiste